[Music]
well welcome back to another episode of
the addie hour it's my privilege of
course to be able to continue hosting
these conversations and today i'm
absolutely honored to be able to host
former congressman patrick j candy for a
conversation about mental health about
politics and about advocacy so obviously
this is a name that i'm sure is familiar
to all of you as listeners but i want to
give due due diligence and do a little
bit of introduction for congressman
kennedy as well
so during his time in congress patrick j
kennedy was the lead author of the
landmark mental health parity and
addiction equity act also known as the
federal parity law which requires
insurers to cover treatment for mental
health and substance use disorders with
no more restrictively than they would
for treatment for illnesses of the body
as founder of the candy forum he now
unites advocates policy makers and
business leaders to advance
evidence-based practices and policies in
mental health and addiction
in 2017 he was appointed to the
president's commission on combating drug
addiction and the opioid crisis
he currently serves as co-chair of the
national action alliance specifically
for the suicide prevention's mental
health and suicide prevention national
response to coven 19 and he serves as
co-chair of the bipartisan policy
center's behavioral health integration
task force
so someone who has been about this work
for a very long time
i did mention to the congressman before
we got on the air that i had the
privilege of actually hearing him speak
at an event back in 2014 here in new
haven a global health and the arts event
and i was struck by just his candor and
sharing his story and really trying to
move things forward
i will also say that other person though
it's been just
a joy and an honor for me to see the
ways that he's continued to be about
this work on so many different levels
really addressing things like stigma of
course thinking about policy also
thinking about access to care insurance
but then also tying in and making sure
that we have an understanding of what
happens in mental illness and
understanding the brain and really
having research to move that forward so
i'm absolutely honored again to be able
to welcome former congressman patrick j
kennedy to the addie hour
thank you dr addie it's a pleasure to be
with you and i just want to thank you on
behalf of all my fellows who have
benefited from professions of psychiatry
and psychology for all you've done to
try to face the challenge that we're
facing as a nation
by dedicating your careers and your
you know mission to to really helping
people not only on a medical level but
just really help them
you know build back some agency and
reclaim their lives and no longer kind
of be marginalized because
society would do that to them ordinarily
and so thank you so much you do have a
spiritual dimension to your job
which is underappreciated because
when you're restored to physical
uh well-being you know the
transformations to your family and
community are so enormous but that's not
often appreciated
in the work that you do so thank you for
that of course and thank you thank you
for those kind words um and in a lot of
ways this podcast in addition to you
know what i do on a professional level
has been i'm a joy to be able to pull so
many different people together as you
alluded to as well
even as you talked about the spiritual
component and just to be able to have
different people come together
in this podcast forum but just even in
the event that you did back in 2014 to
see researchers and clinicians
and actors and and public advocates all
in the same space trying to move these
things forward um so i know we're
complimenting each other here but i
think it's just important to acknowledge
how important that is in terms of really
trying to move things forward um and
it's just um
it's just an honor to do that you know
gratitude is a mindset an attitude i've
learned to cultivate in recovery from
addiction and mental illness and the
default mode for my brain is to think
about the negative to ruminate about
my fears
of losing what i have or not getting
what i want
and part of my mental well-being is to
transform that thought process which is
negative to one there where because i'm
trained through cognitive behavioral
therapy which is what 12-step recovery
is to me
to always look every day in a humble way
how i can be of service to someone
else that gets me out of my own
self-centered uh thinking and and so i
want to say that this is not out of some
like
pure adulation or sucking up to you i
just want to really point out to your
listeners that uh
this is about living life differently
and um it saves us to be
trying to be open to other people and
so i was grateful to be invited to be on
this of course of course and that's so
well said and i appreciate even the way
that you've already just started to take
us on your journey and to show us the
importance of that as we walk through
those different aspects and have that
different approach and that different
mindset all the things that we can do
with kind of behavioral therapy and how
important that is for us as we're
walking through these journeys so i'm
already appreciative of the you know i
knew you'd be able to bring that level
of candor and
and insight and grateful that you've
already even started to share that in
this moment
and even to follow up on that as my
listeners know i always like to start
out and you've done this already just
checking in and seeing how people are
doing in the midst of everything that
we're continuing to experience as a
society obviously there are so many
things that are going on at this point
in time even as we were in the middle of
the hearings around the january 6th
situation all the things that we're
continuing to walk through just as we
continue to navigate the pandemic as
people are still getting sick as we're
experiencing you know tragic situation
after tragic situation but then as we
also have reasons for hope and the work
that we do as you've alluded to and just
the joy that we can have from being in
community with one another so that was a
long-winded introduction but just to say
i wanted to start there and see just how
you're doing at this point in time
i appreciate that so um
i i really feel the biology in my brain
is what is
where i sink or swim because i really
feel overwhelmed
throughout the week here and there but
because of that issue of cognitive
behavioral therapy because i know
that feelings aren't facts but in
recovery i know that we i used to drink
and drug over feelings
even they're not even though they're not
facts like so i learn in recovery to
take a gratitude list of all the great
things in my life because i have to do a
reality check
because even if with everything as you
said is so
unhinged around us in the world today
and we're really off kilter in my view
in our culture society just in
the toxicity of our political culture
the uh obviously existential crisis of
our environment these shootings
uh you know the feeling of safety
uh all jeopardized
very big issues that could really sink
anyone the key here is how do i respond
and react that's how i'm taught in
recovery is now what's going on how do i
react to what's going on
and uh i do it by then talking about
like you said the hopeful things uh
my
four-year-old came into my bed this
morning and put his hand
on my face like
that you know his effect that he's so
affectionate
i just i lay there and was just soaked
that in because it was like one of the
best parts of the day yesterday i got to
give him you know in a
mop-up
bin where you put all the water just to
do the mop i i fit him in he fit into
this
uh bin of water wow and had a bubble
bath and it was just
myself like i can see that as a joy
today and that relieves
the tension and the stress of having to
kind of ruminate about all that's going
on in the world that i
like every other american and anyone
else in the world i could easily get
carried away
by
well such a helpful perspective and
great stories too i know as someone who
is also a neuroscientist i'm also you
know i'm resonating with what you're
saying about the brain and thinking
about all those aspects as well i mean
even topics that we've talked about even
just our interactions with their family
members and what that does to our brains
and the oxytocin that gets released and
as you said that just helps us kind of
move through and these even as you're so
proactive about that mindset shift um
and really using that to move through so
i appreciate it dr addy i love the
neuroscience because
you know i read
the dopamine nation by one of your
colleagues out in the in stanford talk
about how
you know we're constantly in our society
trying to push all the buttons to flood
our brains with dopamine
and another way of saying is we're
engaged in kind of addictive behaviors
to try to feed
uh our feeling of anxiety to medicate
that and you can do it beyond just drugs
and alcohol i'm in recovery from active
use of drugs and alcohol but i can feel
those dopamine receptors by quote acting
out in any number of the seven deadly
sins because they give me a short burst
but in that neuroscience story it shows
me that i have a hangover whether i
have drank too much or drugged too much
or act out too much
on any number of the
dopamine stimuli that i could try to use
to self-medicate anyway what i'm saying
to your audience is that understanding
the neuroscience
really helps me think about this more
than just as a philosophical issue it
explains why i want to be in recovery
because
that is actually uh makes me feel better
right you know i love you're mentioning
the oxytocin because i hold on to my
babies and i i get all close up that i
got five kids because i know that it's
like
it's it's not medicating for me just to
give them hugs and i know for them it's
key because i know their brains are
developing and i want them to be solid
foundations and it's not enough for me
just to not drink and drug because i
know that makes them feel better
but because i want to reinforce kind of
positive feelings of of agency for them
and yeah awareness so that's great i
love hearing you share about that and
just all the things that that does you
know to our reward centers as we talk
about as well and then even as you are
talking you know as i do addiction
research and we find that you know even
if we're doing things in rats or mice if
they play and have that time it makes it
much less likely they'll take more
substance or take to excess so it's
wonderful to just hear you you know
elaborate on that and give these stories
as well and just to hear the passion in
your voice because i can really see how
that passion has infiltrated into all
the work that you've done on so many
different fronts um especially with the
candy forum and so many other things
so as you've been you know highlighting
those pieces i wonder if you also just
share a little bit about how the candy
forum came about what was the journey
that brought you to this place and then
at some point we'll delve into some of
the work that you do within the within
the organization as well
well um you know i got elected as a
state legislator at 21 in rhode island's
the youngest member i was
elected at 26 to congress as the
youngest member of congress and then
chosen to be in leadership at 31. i can
guarantee you dr addy none of it had to
do with my last name being kennedy
whatsoever
it was all my good looks and personality
that got me so far of course of course
so so there's something very powerful
about
my uncle president kennedy's new
frontier the message of of hopefulness
that he gave when he embarked on the
peace corps
when he set a vision for going to the
moon under in under 10 years which was
thought of as being way over his skis at
the time and it's just aspirational
aspects of his um leadership and that
still resonates to people today who are
looking for narrative
and context
so i've woven his work on civil rights
for example as the first president to
speak about that as a moral issue when
he said who amongst us would trade the
color of their skin and then be content
with those who counsel patients and
delay in other words the golden rule how
would you like to be treated think about
what it's like to have
different colored skin and be living in
this country where you know you're still
feeling
as though the country doesn't accept you
and you know the racialization of many
institutions this country that still
you know
is so demoralizing to our friends and
neighbors
uh who have different color skin who
don't feel fully accepted in america
anyway my point is is that these notions
are very helpful when i'm advocating for
mental health and ironically my family
was very uh
stigmatizing on mental illness they were
real visionaries and leaders
but you know president kennedy signed
the first community mental health act
but um
you know
he grew up in a family where no one
spoke about his sister's intellectual
disability in fact after my grandfather
chose to have a lobotomy for her and and
that was clearly unsuccessful and she
was kind of put out in a monastery in
wisconsin
never to be seen or heard of again wow
right
that shame was so palpable in my
father's life you know and then
thankfully my aunt eunice
you know finally got the approval from
her brother to speak about it openly
when he went after he was elected
president
and then from that came the special
olympics which is now in over 190
countries around the world and
transforming the view towards people
with intellectual disabilities but my
point is the silence and shame
that accompanied
that that that
terrible situation with my aunt rosemary
which by the way was also fueled by a
psychiatric illness many believe that
she had a kind of form of bipolar which
coupled with their intellectual
disability letter to outbursts that made
my grandparents very uncomfortable which
is what led to the lobotomy
you know it's about talking about this
in a way that isn't stigmatizing
and you know when i did mental health
and addiction
that was very uh
you know shameful in my family my mother
suffered from profound
alcoholism and depression my father
self-medicated he was traumatized by his
brother's
assassination his murders
i mean um but but
you know
it was still that way you know and my
father is a very forward-thinking guy
but it was hard for him to get past his
generation's view of mental health and
addiction as a character flaw
as opposed to a chemistry issue and
i found that in the course of my
advocating i was trying to
break this
the shackles of living in that silence
and the imprisonment because i not only
did i suffer from these illnesses
as i said my whole family did and there
was something i knew i i had to do and
by the way i didn't choose to do this i
the guy that i was in drug rehab with
sold his story of being in drug rehab to
the national enquirer which outed me
and
dr addy that ended up being the best
thing that ever happened to me in my
life because instead of like
making this a closely guarded secret
when i got to washington um i had
already been out so i could put my name
first on a bill that said mental health
ought to be treated the same because
unlike my colleagues who are much more
senior than me who could have been the
sponsors
of that bill none of them wanted to
answer why they were a sponsor of a bill
that had both the words mental and
addiction in the title because of course
press would naturally ask well have you
had any of these issues in your life no
one else wanted to answer them but
because i was a kennedy i was exposed
early i hated it at the time
but it ended up being one of the best
things that ever happened to me
wow that's amazing to hear the the
backstory for that too because even as
you were talking i was you know because
as you talked about the stigma kind of
being pervasive what it was it really
helped you push through that to say that
there needs to be a shift and it sounds
like there was some
i don't know serendipity is the right
word but
not that you wouldn't have wanted to but
there was a situation that allowed you
to step into that and so i really you
know applaud you for making that shift
and as you alluded to it's not that
others wouldn't have been navigating
that as well i mean if we think about
our current statistics one in five who
are living currently with a mental
illness so when we think about people in
government and politics that includes
all of us so for you to really be able
to take that step and move it forward i
think it's so important
would you say you've seen shifts in the
perspective amongst when you're in
congress amongst your colleagues from
moving that forward because i can you
know reading through kind of the process
of it and
anticipate i'm sure that there was
pushback with that along the way as well
um so what was that process like and
what have you seen shift over time so
because these are chronic illnesses just
because i went to treatment at 17 didn't
mean i was done
i constantly grappled with this and of
course i still tried to keep it secret
um because of course i i assumed even as
the champion of parity that was supposed
to be better right
okay and of course our health care
system never treated my illness the way
it does my asthma which is a chronic
illness and needs constant attention it
just is a a kind of um acute episodic
treatment system right that doesn't
reimburse for the chronic care nature of
these illnesses so that's a long way of
saying when i got a dwi because my
illness still hadn't uh you know
you know survive been succeeded in terms
of its um treatment
because we these are chronic illnesses
um
i
i went to it was very shameful and i
went to treatment and it looked as
though i was going to have to leave
congress
i got a lot of letters um from
colleagues
telling me and that they were pulling
for me which really you know folks that
i had never talked to before when i was
serving with them when i got back from
um treatment i i went and visited many
of them to thank them and it was the
first time i'd ever had them tell me
about their own challenges
and then i realized i was in a unique
place because i was the only one who had
mental illness and addiction tattooed to
his forehead because that i was the only
one of their colleagues that they knew
when in fact now i had the opposite uh
benefit i had the the eyes on the fact
that so many of my colleagues had
similar challenges in them their own
lives and their families lives that none
of the other ones of them knew about but
i had that secret um perspective which i
kept secret because they asked me to but
but i s i met a lot of my colleagues and
uh uh some of them
uh who who told me very harrowing
stories about their own families mental
illness and addiction voted against our
mental health parity and addiction
equity act
and i never outed them or challenged
them on it i did talk to them later on i
said how could you have voted a no on
that bill i thought you told me about
you know uh suicide in your family your
daughter's eating disorder and so forth
and they said well well patrick i don't
come from the same part of the country
you come from
i come from the buccal of the bible belt
um your constituents may be all right
re-electing you but i can't be sure mine
would re-elect me if they knew
and and then they said something even
more powerful they said frankly when i
think about it if my child ever felt
that they were exposed i can't be sure
what they would do
which of course the end of that sentence
is i can't be sure whether they wouldn't
take their lives
because of the shame of these illnesses
so
i mean that still shows you that um
we made progress but there's still a lot
of caveats to that progress
i also tell people like we passed this
law but it wasn't because everybody woke
up one day and said oh wouldn't it be
good thing that we cover the brain like
we would every other organ of the body
we passed this law because um chris dodd
was a friend of my families
and
and our bill in the house was the better
of the two bills and i got chris to pass
our bill h.r 1424 by writing the whole
economic stabilization act of 2008 which
is the toxic asset relief program in
other words the seven to eight hundred
billion dollar bailout of jamie dimon
and all the big bankers that got us into
this mess in the first place with our
meltdown and banking crisis in 2008.
that's how we got the parity bill passed
so when george bush signed
um the
parity law he was really signing it
because it contained
the provisions to get our country out of
getting into another financial great
depression he wasn't signing it because
it mandated coverage for depression
so um
you know the bottom line is we
up until covet i haven't seen any
traction on mental health and since the
time i left congress until today
i have been pushing for the enforcement
of the mental health party law really to
no avail all of the leading psychiatric
hospitals and
addiction treatment providers
really did not put their shoulder behind
this even though this was good for them
and the reason was is because they
didn't want to offend the big payers
because all of them were so dependent on
the uniteds and aetnas and anthems and
cygnus
and so it was interesting to me the very
people who should have been the most
supportive
were kind of the most reticent and i
thought to myself if we can't get the
ver very providers who benefit from this
law to support its implementation
how am i going to get everyone else to
support it who
you know feels stigmatized because these
illnesses
so
we're finally getting some attention but
dr addy it's because corporate america
is nervous
that their you know the great
resignation
and the competition for talent
means that they better do something on
mental health because these gen xers uh
and and others these young
workforce is demanding no less
and they know
intuitively that if they don't invest in
mental health not only is it a cost on
their total work health care costs in
their workforce but it's a cost to their
economic productivity
and but but still today
uh dr eddie we have not wrapped our arms
around the full economic implications
of
poor mental health
and the full benefits of real good
integrated mental health into the rest
of physical health care and until we do
it's going to be still a push and pull
to get corporations to do what's in
their self-interest to get insurance
companies to get past this gatekeeper
idea that all they need to be doing in
this world is limiting
uh you know cost and access which is
counterproductive in every way as we
know from the early data so
it's still a long ways to go yeah the
long haul and i appreciate that i mean
you that's a very the way you're giving
us the full context i mean even from the
early work and the
strategy involved in that and how you
had to you know partner with others to
really move things along in a certain
way but it sounds like you're also being
very savvy about the motivation
behind that as well um and now you're
kind of touching on this do you feel
like there you know with everything
that's happened with covet is there any
shift whatsoever or any greater
acknowledgement that you think will help
move things forward or is it still
just all these aspects of resistance
that you've talked about there are still
kind of the major roadblocks
so the 800 pound gorilla is that we
don't have enough workers
to meet the current crisis we're not
going to have near the workers we need
to meet the future mental health crisis
we've got a tsunami the racial pandemic
the covet pandemic the economic
dislocation moving into more techno
uh technical technology based economies
the dislocation of workers the global
implications uh
ukraine
the virus
uh you know the environment
i mean it's just no shortage and we're
really not using as i said earlier our
prefrontal cortex where we're really
acting out of our
you know mammalian brain you know our
amygdala is in full flight
and
i really think we need neuro literacy in
this country in other words i think you
know a generation ago corporate america
pushed stem education you know they
didn't think we had enough scientists
technologists
mathematicians china was eating our
lunch you know the rest of the world was
advancing so corporate america said oh
we gotta teach this in our schools and
that's what we ended up shifting our
educational paradigm we're gonna need to
do the same
on neuro literacy and the reason i'm
saying is if we don't have the next
generation of workers able to manage
cope with stress
we're not going to have a productive
workforce
and
and i think this existential crisis in
corporate america with the great
resignation and
i think it's got them thinking oh my god
like what are we gonna do like this is a
whole new generation they're not
subscribing to the old traditional
paradigm of work and what is it going to
mean to have them work for us how are we
going to make sure they're
optimal in their capacity and we retain
them
i just think that it's going to now
require that they really go back and
think how are we producing
people in this world
in a way where they can be much more
productive and it's basically about a
prevention model because if we don't
have that then stress as you know is the
is the environmental factor that can tip
off the genetic predisposition
to all array of mental illnesses and
addictions particularly
so the key is to interrupt
that that stress
where possible through tools that people
can use
so that their predisposition if they
have a greater vulnerability to
depression and anxiety or needing
alcoholism that they they can
acknowledge that and then
intervene and do these things that we're
just talking about
go outside connect with family
understand the value
of
interpersonal relationships
um to their own mental health so
yeah i think there's a lot to wrap our
arms around here yeah well so many
important pieces of what you've pulled
out too as well i mean as you
acknowledge just the workforce shortage
but then also just the need for the
workforce to be infiltrated in a sense
and obviously that can be a challenge
when there aren't enough that i'm
thinking you know in terms of clinicians
and researchers and just being out in
the community and helping with this with
this literacy as it were so to speak um
and all the just different things that
you've highlighted of all the needs that
are there that where things really need
to kind of push
and move forward
so going back to something we mentioned
at the you know the top of the episode
too even just thinking about hope in the
midst of everything because you've
obviously had some things that have been
put into place that aren't necessarily
being implicated as much as they should
but at the same time you're continuing
to move things forward even in the midst
of that so i'm thinking about all the
different initiatives that you've been
involved in i'm thinking about one mind
i'm thinking about the candy status
center for mental health equity at the
morehouse school of medicine which
seemed like it was pioneering in many
ways
speaking about and moving forward in
those aspects i'm thinking about the
work that you've been
i'm involved in and the all that's going
on with the wit and the united
behavioral health
case as well
so i'm wondering even in the midst of
the challenges how do you see hope in
the midst of what you're trying to do in
some of these efforts because i've also
heard you say things like and you've
alluded to that here that we need to get
to a new normal so how do you how do you
balance those two i guess this is also
it's a little bit of a personal question
but also a little bit of a
programmatic question in terms of how
you just go about this work on a
day-to-day basis with all that needs to
be done
well i
i get on my knees in the morning i try
to humble myself
and think about what my greatest purpose
and utility is and i know
as i mentioned earlier
you know i may not have had the smartest
you know
best grade point average or the best
this i've been blessed with this family
narrative that i think is very conducive
to
pulling these different strings together
and creating a narrative i think we've
missed the narrative in this because we
have addiction over here and mental
illness over here and then people with
mental wellness issues aren't seeing
themselves in either bucket we just
don't have this holistic picture that
this is good for everybody
green berets have more mental health
than any other branch of the service and
how do i know that because john f
kennedy awarded the wearing of the green
beret and i went and rededicated the
fort bragg special warfare school named
for john f kennedy and it was at that
that general hugh shelton first chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff came up to
me and said uh congressman we have more
mental health for our green berets than
any other branch of the service and i
knew he'd seen my cv
so i thought to myself well he's just
being political so i said general listen
these green berets they don't need
mental health they jump out of airplanes
and they
they hit the water and they they they
swim underwater for five miles without
breathing and then they hit the beach
and they speak six languages and they
take out their target and they're
reading to their kids by dinner time
they don't need mental health and
general shelton said congressman you
don't understand and i was like take
them back like
uh what and he said we look at mental
health as a force multiplier
and i thought to myself brilliant i had
never heard that before i just thought
of mental health as being about deficits
i never thought about mental health
being that glass was half full like
you mean people who are strong also need
mental health and so i asked him about
it he said yeah we need our special
operators to to work at their optimal
full capacity
um and and so i was like that makes
sense
and my point is is that that and then my
family history of civil rights got me
this perspective like
when david satru i'd worked with when he
was surgeon general was the first
surgeon general to do a mental health
report called on me after i left
congress said do you want to be part of
morehouse school of medicine
i mean first i had to say yes because
david satcher was in jail
with dr king amongst a lot of young
student protesters at the time and to my
view of growing up they're part of our
founding fathers they're the ones who
lay the groundwork for a modern day
america where
we
pass the civil rights act voting rights
out fair housing act fair employment all
which laid the ground ground for
progress in this country for more
americans to be included in the circle
of opportunity
and as opposed to us just being an elite
selective society of just a few people
who had
all the power so i said yes
that was you know
10 years before george floyd
i had no idea
because as most white americans like
this thing that we now saw with george
floyd was happening every single day in
america we just weren't we didn't have
it captured on video like it was so
painfully captured
when when george floyd was killed
and since then there's been 229
additional black people have been killed
the hands of police since george floyd
i i only know that i i i
tragically to say because i've been
pulled into morehouse because of dr
satcher his relationship with my family
my relationship with him to be have a
little bit broader perspective than i
would have otherwise
and so i've been the one who's learned
about what is vicarious trauma
and when others tell me it well it's
like seeing your family members kill
routinely on
television and these photos
because of the color of their skin
you know and i can i have to go into my
closet one of my friends said and take
out all the hoodies in my closet because
i'm worried my son is going to be killed
i'm saying to myself that's not my
experience
and and then it dawns on me i have a
moral obligation to do everything i can
because if that were me i can't imagine
the rage that i would have
if my family members were constantly
stopped because they were suspected of
of
committing some type of crime because
that's how we've racialized our criminal
justice system
in any event
all of this dr addy is not out of my
personal choice i have been born in an
environment that has
worked on me and shaped me
which i owe my you know
existence to so when i think about
what do we need to do i think about
trying to tie this together
um as a modern day medical version
of
of civil rights because if you think
about it mental health is separate
and unequal
and you think about people who suffer
from mental illness marginalized and by
the way
like black people shot inordinately
during emergency response vis-a-vis the
general population and like with
communities of color also incarcerated
at much bigger numbers
right than the yeah so so you've got a
lot of the same dynamics i never would
have made those
connections had i not had my life
experiences so when i say i get down on
my knees i think about well what's my
job
it's to move with the what i've been
given i've been given these ways of
looking at the world
um which helped me in my view
advance this advocacy and by the way i
can advance it because
i got this family name
i've got connections to the corridors of
power
i can bring attention and i don't have
to feel diminished because i also have
depression
and anxiety i also have drug addiction
you know i don't have to
whereas if i didn't have my last name
maybe i wouldn't be so racing to the
door to be an advocate because let's be
honest if people were just to look at me
as someone who's in recovery from a
mental illness or addiction
i could easily be dismissed
so i feel like i have
and by the way i spent a better part of
my day helping my friends get connected
to care just in the microworld
and also calling up my friends from
insurance companies saying you got to
cover this person it's your legal
obligation and they do it
but that's only because that's what what
god has given me to do with what i have
been given in my life so yeah um finding
purpose to me is the way to find hope
yeah that's so powerful i mean so so
much of what you said
resonates on so many levels i mean
obviously it's sobering at the same time
it's also refreshing
and just hearing you talk through that
just seeing all the ways that you've
really just walked in community with
others so it sounds like you're not
coming in saying that you you have all
this understanding already but you're
partnering with with people
who are trusted
who are colleagues who are friends even
as you talked about dr stature and
learning from people's experiences and
just the way that you have been able to
incorporate that and get that level of
understanding grant that you didn't walk
through it yourself but just even as you
related to the rage that you would feel
if you were in that similar situation i
would say that's so
important that even you know even as
you're saying i'm still kind of just
processing and taking in all the again
the passion that's there and the ways
that you've really been adamant about
putting it into practice and making sure
that it's something that can really
help us shift and move how we go about
these things on a on a day-to-day basis
so just against gratitude for
the ways that you've acknowledged the
the the role that you have the
opportunity that you have in walking
alongside others to really make sure
that that comes
to fruition in so many different ways
yeah i know i mean uh of course
um my i've voted against defense of
marriage act i was signing on everything
civil rights uh lgbtq
you know it was politically the right
thing to do right that's from my mindset
you know i have a i have a family member
a daughter now who's grappling with
identity i could never have imagined
why the work that i did
you know decade two ago around this
issue
could come home
right
so we and and i try to tell people even
if you haven't had a mental illness or
addiction in your family
it's going to come home to you at some
point and what kind of world do you want
for your life
do you want to have to wait six months
before you can see dr addy because
that's right now
what it takes to get a really good
psychiatric uh you know uh
hearing and
and then
what kind of
therapeutic are you going to just be set
shipped off to
some kind of one-size-fits-all approach
or
is your loved one going to kind of get
the curated best evidence-based
treatment for their particular diagnosis
so
i i was fortunate to get great psychiat
psychiatric care myself but i didn't get
cognitive behavioral therapy dr addy i
was
and i'm very much interested in getting
cbt
um more adopted just generally and and
incentivizing that and having kind of an
angie's list and a match.com set up so
that if i need to get care and if my
daughter
you know has to get some skills
with eating disorders that she's not
going to someone who's just good on
depression anxiety even though she has
depression anxiety like what is it that
she'll need i want therapists that are
going to be good for her right and right
now
she'll be lucky she gets anybody
right yeah not the least of which is
someone who can actually help her with
her particular challenges someone who
can help me with mine so
we need to really ramp up the delivery
of evidence-based treatment in addition
to doing the what the parity law says
and that is pay for it
[Music]
obviously chicken and egg like you gotta
put a lot more money in this yeah but my
hope is that when we put more money in
it we also demand kind of greater
outcomes at the same time
because we have a double problem we have
a truck problem of accessing mental
health but then we have another problem
of accessing quality mental health
and we need to do both and that by the
way takes
you know payers but it and then of
course it takes providers so it's not an
either or we need both of them to be
together in this yeah so challenging as
you mentioned you know with some of the
guests that we've had this program too
even when we talk about you know some of
the severe mental illnesses and
things around suicide prevention as
you're familiar with from your work just
ways that we actually in some ways need
to rebuild the system but what can we do
in the meantime to really help things
move forward um and so again just know
that the work that you're doing is so
important in so many different ways
and wonder if you also just talk a
little bit about you know the ongoing
case and what really needs to shift in
ways that you think that we can do that
to have an impact even with the ongoing
um case i alluded to earlier
yeah well we need advocacy that's the
big missing piece like it's it's not as
if i don't have the whole matrix of
policies
already enumerated by every subcommittee
in the united states congress like we've
never had before
i mean this is not just the purview of
the health committee it's the purview of
the housing committee the labor
committee the education committee
and my point is is that it's a
comprehensive approach but
what we need are we need people to sign
up and some people be interested in the
supportive housing and the community
model others will be about the
neuroscience and coming up with new
pharmaceutical interventions others will
be about expanding and getting rid of
the imd exclusion so people can get
adequate inpatient access to care
um you know expanding the telemental
health
point is is that we just need an
advocacy movement and
we need to look at what the chamber of
commerce has done the league of
conservation voters the afl-cio
you could you can name your advocacy
group they've got it all they've got the
what is the uniform kind of
agenda that unites all of the affiliates
within
organized labor well there's different
types of unions but they all kind of
agree well we need
kind of uh minimum wage fair labor
pensions we need decent health care you
know you've got some standards right um
and and in environment it's you know
it's league of conservation voters yeah
some of us are interested in air
as asthmatic water
land you know it's the whole idea is
yeah but we have a unified agenda these
are the big issues we don't have that in
mental health yet we parody for years
was kind of the singular issue that
united the whole community whether you
have addiction or mental illness whether
you're a psychiatrist or psychologist
we need to bake this so that everybody
sees their own advantage and we get
as i said the
28 million americans in long-term
recovery who are quote anonymous
out of these church basements and
understanding that our founder bill w
testified in front of congress
um that
nothing you can say you're a person
long-term recovery without having to
acknowledge the exact 12-step group that
you belong to and still maintain the
11th tradition
of privacy at the level of press
newspaper and radio so we just don't
have a sophistication and advocacy
that lends itself to ramping these
issues up because my wife ran for
congress this last cycle i could not
get a list of families impacted by this
illness
uh i couldn't get a list of all the
paraprofessionals who treat these
illnesses
i couldn't get i mean i could just keep
going on and on whereas if i wanted to
you know reach
uh working families i had every single
union mailing list i i would make a
phone call there would be an automatic
rally you know my wife went out the wife
went out to do canvassing she'd be a
company with 50 other of her fellow
teachers like we need that in mental
health and addiction and if we don't get
that doctor we can have all these great
policies but they're not going to
translate because we don't put the money
behind them and we don't put the bodies
behind them
and that's what we need the most yeah
just to change all the way around from
like you said to making sure that it's i
mean i'm thinking back to what you said
about the green brace too it seemed like
it was baked into every aspect of what
they did and that was really where it
started and where it ended and how just
wrapped around so as much as we need to
do that on all these different
components as you mentioned on all these
different subcommittees on all these
different topics
so important in so many ways i'm glad
you brought your wife up as well you
know also thinking about you know her
role previously as an educator and how
important
that component is to even as you're
talking about some of the cbt you know i
have some clinical psychology colleagues
who have talked about how they love to
see some of those principles integrated
into the schools from day one so that
people would have these skills being
taught within that system and have these
skills to approach things even as you
mentioned these are not oh you only need
these if you're starting to navigate a
mental illness but these are life skills
mental wellness that we should be
incorporating um so i wonder you know in
the work that you all have done even the
work that your wife has done how is that
perspective in terms of thinking about
education and some of the challenges
around mental health and what needs to
happen there how has that perspective
also
impacted the work that you've been doing
well if you think about it you know
you've got all these points so source
solutions for
obesity or sleep or what have you we we
basically need a life a learning
management system for life where
we kind of like the internet model we
understand how the whole thing works we
know how to do you know
google and we know how to do
we need to have now some of us may have
how do we overcome these um
delusions and you know frankly people
with
psychotic disorders there is you know
kind of behavioral therapy on how to
and there's even with suicide ideation
it's not just simply a matter of
depression
and i know john crystal and others that
yield been really formative in this
it's about a particular type of impulse
control that you can actually do kind of
behavioral therapy around and actually
reduce the suicide rate in this country
and yet we don't use that especially
when we have people come get admitted in
ers for suicide ideation we don't
immediately say hey by the way there's
this program where you can dramatically
reduce the likelihood of you ever dying
by your own hand because now you will
have the tools necessary
when you feel that desperation
uh to not act on it
and
if you could get the the results in
cancer that you can get in mental health
by adopting these evidence base i mean
it'd be a no-brainer plus we'd be paying
for it
we have greater therapeutic
interventions that could make a bigger
uh survival uh difference than all of
these other medical uh
you know
services that get reimbursed to to
oodles of dollars to pay for those
so
and only move the disease burden on the
margins right compared to what would
happen in this space so
i would say that i i really believe we
need to understand kind of at a basic
level what's the handbook in life how do
we understand our brain how it works how
do we maximize our own
challenges and and by the way that could
apply to personal relationships first it
could apply to drugs and alcohol for
others it could apply
um you know to
workplace issues or
you know it's it's the mechanisms that
are the same no matter what your choice
of what's your bedevilements right
um
and that's why the 12-step program
generally is worked across gambling and
narcotics and alcoholism and and obesity
and all because the principles are what
are universal we need to embed that kind
of principles in a learning management
system that allows you to to
customize if you will those principles
for you in your own life
so you learn how to break that default
thinking as it applies to you like
everyone's always after me or they're
all trying to get me or i'm full of
resentments well let's think about how
to dismantle that because it's taken me
offline from being able to achieve what
i want to achieve if people americans
love looking better
feeling better
you know
why not make this the thing that we want
because if it's
if it's happiness we're all for right
fulfillment
contentment the best way to sell that is
to make that sort of uniquely american
consumerism apply to how do i become a
better consumer for my own mental health
um
so that's how i would think about it and
of course you know of course in
education you've got that universal uh
public health approach so you're not
trying to play catch-up
down the line when i'm in my
20s trying to get recovered from
addiction if i had earlier on
you know been equipped to have to be
more aware
um i wouldn't let myself constantly be
kind of
deluded into thinking that i still have
got this like i can manage my life
which is what is the great
um unifying factor of all people with
addiction mental illnesses that they
think they're not as bad as they really
are it's that denial that we talk about
but education is where we could lay the
foundation a really strong future on
mental health yeah i wholeheartedly
agree as much as we can
set those foundations and put those
things in place and more that people
like you and hopefully people like me
and others are partnering to really make
sure that that really becomes embedded
in our in our education our framework
and our mentality um and i'm grateful
you know that some have started to speak
up about it but again there's so much
more that we have to do
around that front as well but it's so so
important as you've enumerated and again
just thinking about even what you're
doing with some of the initiatives even
like one mind and making sure that
there's opportunities for the research
to be done but for also for people to be
able to go out and to talk about that
research and make sure that it's
embedded
in everything that we do i love the
basic science in one mind which is
basically if you take
um
neurodegenerative disorders which are
such a big challenge parkinson's
alzheimer's
and the like
and you look at all the effective
disorders depression anxiety addiction
like
you know you would think that well if
you study the signature wounds of war
traumatic brain injury and
post-traumatic stress which you could
get the defense establishment and by the
way
you know define as a national security
issue which would then
generate the kind of federal investment
that you wouldn't be able to get if you
just defined it as a kind of a medical
issue
you could get the world behind this
these global data sets
that allow us to track various
interventions because the brain is the
most complex organ of the body in order
to decode it you need data on the size
that you've never seen before
and ironically you know to back to this
narrative piece jfk did the race to
space that's when we needed super
computers that's when they started
today
it's the race to inner space that is the
big new frontier right it's it's it's
discovering the galaxy of neurons in our
brain and understanding therapeutic
interventions that can save someone with
als to someone with debilitating ocd
and and by the way if you're studying
parkinson's you have to understand the
dopamine response so you have to
understand depression who would imagine
a neurodegenerative
uh you know illness could also be a big
point of interest for people with
affective disorders in other words we're
all in this together yeah and i just
think that um
the the the
space station concept where the world
sees its kind of combined interest would
be a great kind of because for us to be
saved in america we need to get the
chinese
online with data on as far as brain and
we need australians and the europeans
latin americans i mean we really need to
be global in our approach and we have
the super
computing capacity like never before so
we could really start to understand
this and get real solutions
but we need a narrative and that's what
we've been missing
yeah fully agree the narrative and the
community working together
which is so important again something
that i've definitely seen in your work
on so many different levels as well
i'll say this is you know this podcast
itself is also about community one thing
that we're trying to do also is just
trying to actually incorporate
input and feedback from the listeners as
well so want to pivot slightly and just
also talk about the new hotline on the
988 or forthcoming hotline um that's
being made available one of our
listeners had a question about that and
just if you'd be willing to just kind of
talk about your perspectives on that and
what you see as the
improvements or what that all will mean
for us as a country as you try to move
forward on so many of these important
topics
well as you know our
criminal justice system has been the
default for a lack of a mental health
system
an addiction treatment system so
we end up incarcerating people because
we don't give them the interventions for
their mental illness or addiction
and as you know we incarcerate a greater
percentage of our population than any
other free industrialized nation in the
world
so the indictment is actually on our
justice system that it's not working um
it's not keeping us safe you know there
is 75 recidivism from state prison
within five years 50 within two years
a majority of uh violent crimes are
committed by people who already been in
prison like we we should just look at
this thing and think well where do we
want incarceration we want incarceration
to protect us
but outside of that what do we want we
want to be
making sure that we treat people with
mental illness we treat people with
addiction and we in the 988 we're in the
first opportunity to really seek
fundamental reform in this paradigm
because instead of the police officers
showing up
which as i mentioned earlier if you have
a mental illness or you're a person of
color you're more likely to be shot
and have a much obviously poor response
um let's think about how this 988 eater
you could have
in in communities of color
someone show up that looks like the
community they're coming from
you could have someone show up who's not
only someone looks like the community
but
knows the situations in terms of if it's
a person with mental illness knows how
to de-escalate
and provide the right intervention so
that one they don't get a criminal
record
and therefore they're able to recover
because it's easier to recover if you
can still get a job because you don't
have this conviction sitting over your
head wouldn't it be get too great to get
pre-adjudication
and all that and by the way some of
these service courts like mental health
courts
um drug courts and the like are already
showing the value of this
in rhode island i was really proud to be
part of expanding veterans courts
in the wake of iraq and afghanistan
we had
second highest percentage of our
um guardian reserve war police units
military police and they all came from
rhode island's municipal police
academies and organizations
and what happened was when they came
back from iraq and afghanistan they
found themselves showing up at
incidences where they were arresting
the very fellow officers they had just
served in
afghanistan with and in iraq with who
were suffering from the untreated impact
of post-traumatic stress
and
and so of course it was bothering them
this was happening yeah and why should
we be locking up one of our freedom
fighters one of our veterans because we
didn't adequately take care of their
quote invisible wounds of war but
frankly as you know
our response to the quote invisible
wounds of war has been invisible in many
respects we've tried to ramp up in the
years past but we've been playing catch
up with 22 veterans dying each day
at their own hands so
my point is is that
we need a different emergency response
and um
if we have a different response we get
different outcomes down the line so why
not try to train that up now to do this
you have to build out a whole
continuum of care which as i mentioned
earlier we've so under funded mental
health all these years we don't have an
infrastructure to meet this need
988 in my view dr addy is going to show
the pitfalls of our current system
as being inadequate because when we
stand this up
everyone expects the number of crisis
calls to minimally minimally quadruple
just grow exponentially and we don't
even have the capacity to meet our
current needs
let alone inviting people to use a
three-digit number as opposed to 9-1-1
to call for a mental health crisis
response
and i just think the thing's going to
fall down and implode on itself and then
hopefully
that will spur us into action and we'll
say oh my god we were a little premature
on this or maybe we didn't get ourselves
organized for it enough
and we'll do what we need to do to
follow that up so
um
988 is a big deal honestly there's very
little understanding of it amongst the
local
uh
county municipal level
um officials that are going to be
necessary to put this in into effect and
so if they don't understand it yeah then
and if by the way there's no kind of
really good technical assistance and how
to
then what kind of system because by the
way it's going to change from locale to
locality because some
systems are going to have really good
kind of maybe and care or really good uh
the right number of uh
people to answer the phone but what
about the people to show up to help that
person are there enough of those people
and and what about the places to go so
if you got person answering the call
then you need someone to show up then
you need a place to go like
we we need like the whole continuum yeah
and different places in the country have
different aspects of that continuum
and uh and we'll
it's going to be a while before we do do
this right but i'm glad at least that
we're
moving down this road and in my view
this is the single biggest
policy
paradigm shift in mental health that
we've seen since the parity law
in terms of its implications on the
whole system yeah that's that's saying a
lot that's saying a lot but as you
mentioned i think it's it's the healthy
perspective too just to see where things
are moving but knowing that it will also
likely open up things that also still
need to be done
and so i you know i appreciate you for
sharing that full perspective and you
know as you've been talking as we've
been going through this episode i think
this is also one of those episodes where
hopefully it will facilitate and
encourage people to actually look into
things and actually do some homework
around some of these topics too i mean
so much of what you share is really
about just education across the board
and how we think about these topics and
the work that you've you've been doing
as well so i hope that people will feel
inspired
by the journey that you've been on and
what you've been doing so far but also
inspired to dig in themselves
and to also
look for ways to educate themselves
educate their community members and to
tap into some of these programs as well
but as we wrap up uh any closing
thoughts that you want to leave our
listeners with i mean there's so so many
highlights and so many important things
that you've pulled out in the
conversation but
anything that you really want to leave
folks with i i'd say you know with covid
we got real-time data on everyone today
that got with their co-morbidities and
we've got a public health response
our data on suicide our data on overdose
is two years old and it's it's uh messy
data meaning it doesn't give us the
information we need to make good policy
decisions
we need to systematically really
understand what data we need to to track
to get the right public health response
and also to align the financial
incentives
in our private sector system to pay for
the value that comes from for example
paying for supportive housing
via the inpatient psychiatric care right
maybe we we really need to understand
the social determinants of health as it
impacts mental health along with the
impact of good therapy and good medicine
and all of these other things and good
providers
so
i would just encourage people to you
know lean in on this this to me is the
big
you know we've got a lot of big issues
to solve but if we don't solve the
mental health piece
we're not going to get around the
toxicity of our political culture we're
not going to be able to think straight
about how to solve some of these
environmental challenges because of the
you know us ignoring the global um
warming we're not going to be able to
deal with all of these issues of of
racial pandemic and
public health pandemic
if we don't really get to be stronger in
our understanding ourselves and how we
relate how we communicate how our brains
work
so a lot to do i'm thrilled to be on
your uh podcast and that you've got
listeners that are interested in this
and uh
please uh well i know we'll put in the
um
links you know some of the work that
we're doing in case anyone's interested
in uh being part of it of course
well congressman kennedy thank you so
much for your time for all the things
that you shared i know me personally i'm
going to go back and re-listen to this
because there's so many
important gems that you dropped
throughout this episode and just you
know i just again appreciate the way you
put things in full context both in terms
of things that have been put in place
then also the work that needs to be done
and where things have stalled so i think
you know i think also speaking from a
mental health advocacy standpoint i
think it's always important to hold both
of those
together as we try to move forward and
then i'm wrapping it up again just
thinking about the hope and just the
importance of community um even as you
talked about your time with your family
and your kids and i feel like hopefully
for you even in this conversation it's
been very generative in that sense no so
i think this is also a representation of
that even on so many levels as we try to
partner together in these efforts across
our society so thank you again for
taking the time and for being here
thanks nate and i look forward to
meeting you in person yeah that would be
wonderful
[Music]